bonjour à tous je suis sécoué le tectec
savez-vous ce qu'est la bourse je vous
explique aujourd'hui de quoi il s'agit
alors c'est quoi la bourse la première
bourse a été créée au 15e siècle en 1409
il s'agit de la Bourse de Brugge en
Belgique la Bourse est comme un marché
mais qui concerne des personnes qui ont
des besoins de financement ce sont par
exemple les entreprises pour financer
leur projet mais elles concernent aussi
des personnes des épargnants et des
sociétés comme les banques qui veulent
investir les titres échangés en bourse
sont les actions les actions
représentent des morceaux du capital
d'une entreprise comme si l'entreprise
était divisée en part d'un gâteau
lorsqu'un investisseur croit en la
capacité d'une entreprise de gagner de
l'argent il va acheter ses actions et
grâce à celle-ci il gagnera de l'argent
à quoi ça sert la bourse la Bourse est
un marché qui réunit lieux de
financement et de placement d'argent les
entreprises peuvent décider de faire
partie de la bourse afin de recevoir de
l'argent pour financer leur projet ou
financer le projet d'autres entreprise
c'est un bon moyen pour elles de se
développer et d'étendre leurs activités
surtout en période de crise où la
recherche d'investisseur se fait
difficile existe-t-il plusieurs types de
Bours oui il y a deux types de Bours
tout d'abord nous avons les bourses des
valeurs comme la Bourse de Paris qui est
la bourse française ce type de bourse
régit uniquement des transferts
d'actions et d'obligations les actions
sont des titres de propriété qui donnent
le droit à la personne qui les achète de
posséder une partie des bénéfices de
l'entreprise et de participer à la
gestion de l'entreprise les obligations
sont des titres de créance c'est-à-dire
un emprunt le deuxième type de bourse
est la Bourse de commerce comme la
Bourse de Chicago où sont négociées les
matières premières telles que le lait le
bois le cacao le riz et bien d'autres
produits qu'est-ce que le cours de la
bourse le cours est la valeur d'un titre
il permet de suivre l'évolution des prix
des matières première et des actions il
est sujet à des variations plus ou moins
fortes même au cours d'une seule journée
j'espère que vous avez bien compris ce
que la bourse à bientôt pour un nouvel
épisode